In this video, we're going to show you how you can automate content discovery with Berberspeed Professional.
Now before you start, you'll need to populate the sitemap with some content before you can use the content discovery tool.
If you'd like a tutorial on how to do this, you can view our documentation page on mapping the visible attack surface.
Now the first thing we're going to do with our populated sitemap is go to Target Sitemap and then find the root node for the domain where we want to discover the content.
For the demo, I'm going to use gillandjuice.shop which is a deliberately vulnerable site which we at Portswigger have made to demonstrate vulnerability scanners.
We're going to right click this root node and then go down to Engagement Tools and then Discover Content.
Here, we're going to click Session is not running and this will start the content discovery session.
You can see the tasks which are queued for the content discovery and as the content discovery tool discovers content, it will add it to the target sitemap.
And you can also view the sitemap that the content discovery tool builds in the sitemap option here.
And that is how you automate content discovery within Berberspeed Professional.
And that is how you use the task to do.